um okay and here we have the the
um ivory uh
and a site of the infamous moon door
it's given many people nightmares yeah i
worked very closely with ted on all of
these
this was the first art that was done for
this book i i wanted uh
i wanted accurate versions of these
castles we've had a number of different
artists draw them
on covers and you know on the fantasy
flight cards and games and some of them
have been
beautiful images but not necessarily
accurate to what i described
but i knew with ted naismith we were
getting one of the great landscape
painters of of the
of the world really and a guy who does
really great architectural work
so he and i work very closely on these
and going back and forth on them until
we got them
pretty much as i see them in my in my
mind's eye
this one looks like the king ludwig
castle
in bavaria uh definitely yeah definitely
inspired by that
but ludwig didn't think of the sky cells
which is
uh that was that was my own perverse
invention
[Laughter]
all right um this is the red keep at
king's landing
um so you already answered one of my
questions which was
you know how well these match your own
vision
of the place no you don't want to talk
about the tv show too much
but um which of the locations do you
feel
the most true to what you imagined
uh in the tv show yeah
um
well there are locations i mean we're
shooting you know in belfast
we're shooting in uh we shot some in
scotland
belfast and northern ireland is our main
location was also shot in iceland
we're shooting in spain right now we've
done a lot in croatia
we've used morocco and malta
in past years so there's many many
different
actual existing locations that uh that
have been used over
over the years none of them are exactly
what i described in my book
but they sure are gorgeous i mean i
think with
probably the best looking show on
television
and some of the interior sets are pretty
amazing too
do you get frustrated ever when it's not
quite what you imagined
i would say i wouldn't say frustrating i
mean sometimes it's it's better you know
i think
like their their version of the high
hall of the aarons
uh with the moon door and the floor is
probably better than my moon door which
is just a door set in the wall
uh because i didn't think of putting it
in the floor
that was pretty cool